[Musique]
1800 athlètes 16 disciplines 2300
encadrants et des centaines de bénévoles
les Jeux des îles de l'Océan Indien
mobiliseront toutes les forces de la
réunion autour d'en main mais seul thème
l'universalité du sport représenter la
Réunion une fierté pour tous ces
sportifs salué hier lors d'une cérémonie
autour de la flamme du côté du village
coraille le porte-drapeau de la
délégation sptif et mérite est fier très
fier d'avoir été choisi c'était un grand
honneur déjà de combattre pour la
Réunion et c'est d'autant plus une
fierté que de pouvoir représenter tous
les sportifs rayignonnais pour ces Jeux
des îles premier souvenir déjà c'éit les
Jeux des îles de 98 mon grand frère
avvec combat et tous mes camarades mes
entraîneurs avec combat c'était la
génération un peu d'avant et c'était ça
faisait partie de mes objectifs de de
pouvoir faire les Jeux des îles et après
toutes les compétitions internationales
que M' fait m'a loupé à chaque fois les
Jeux des îles et tout et là l'occasion
de pouvoir les faire et en plus d'être
pour drapeau c'était le SOMUM de du de
nombreuses personnalités politiques et
sportives avec entre autres Nassima
Dindar présidente du conseil
départemental Didier Robert président de
région et Jeux des îles et les sportifs
réunionnés bénéficient des aides des
collectivités ce qui permet pour
certains sportifs d'évoluer sur le plan
national voire international mais Nassim
malandar a surtout rappelé l'importance
des liens qui unissent les îles de
l'Océan Indien vous représentez vous
représentez comme comme les sportifs de
Maurice de Madagascar des sécheles des
Comores de maotte vous représentez
pour la Réunion la réunion de
l'excellence l'océan Indien de
l'excellence vous êtes notre fierté mais
vous êtes aussi des modèles des sportifs
et des sportives fiers de représenter la
réunion à l'image de la sélection
réunion de foot féminin il fait plaisir
parce que voilà depuis jou football et
un moment donné on envie de de que les
gens en fait déjà être comme ça en
sélection elle est belle parce que c'est
une fierté représente la Réunion c'est
un joli lî pour qu' va on va mett encore
plus en l'air encore parmi les 16
disciplines représentées du foot mais
aussi du basket surtout que MAOM il est
là-bas et revenir ici devant ma famille
jouer devant ma famille même toutes mes
copines d'avant et Cera mais est très
très important pour moi de représenter
mon île n amis vient et voilà créer une
vraie cohésion au-delà des disciplines
et permettre aux athlètes d'être tous
derrière le drapeau reignonné c'est la
vocation de ces 9e jeux des îes fa
échanger faire rencontrer les gensant
dans le village à l'extérieur que le
public Vienne puisse rencontrer les
autres et également peut-être permettre
des échanges qui vont se curer après
c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en place le
camp des jeunes car ce camp où des
jeunes vont voir observer est-ce que
cette fraternité se joue entre les
athlètes et les différents membres de
chaque délégation le club réunion se
constitue de plus en plus c'est c'est la
cohésion du groupe et c'est créé un
esprit d'équipe et un esprit chez les
athlètes qui qui vont défendre les
couleurs d'un pays qui vont les couleurs
de le î de leur discipline et qu'il va
falloir le faire au mieux rendez-vous
pour la compétition mais surtout pour la
fête à partir du 1er et ce jusqu'au 9
août pour se mettre dans l'ambiance
petit extrait du AK des filles de
l'équipe de
[Musique]
foot
I